what's up guys I'm Jim Gettys i'm here
with colin moriarty at a very special
guest andre meadows Andre hey everyone
in tender today all right it remained
self to the people though they might not
know hi case you don't know my name is
Andre area have the youtube channel
black nerd comedy I do reviews
interviews sketches rants and everything
all about geek culture in the sounds of
culture and and gaming culture including
Nintendo especially Nintendo also yeah
so obvious general fanboys everybody
knows yeah Colin I'm like what i call a
lapsed intendo fan yes at one point
Colin was in love with the big end ya
know recent years have I broke up mom's
now yeah yeah but you know what there's
always things for room for a little
rekindling about you always curious
where your ex-girlfriends doing exactly
no you always check it on Facebook you
looking at her Instagram yeah
relationships and so that's when Colin
watches Nintendo to Rex that's what it
is like keeping up on the extroverts
corn yeah yeah it's complicated yeah but
speaking of the direct what do you think
it was interesting a lot of it it's
stuff we had seen before I'd heard about
before but Star Fox zero obviously it
was one of my face as well as Super
Mario maker which i think is going to be
like half a YouTube videos will be this
Super Mario maker without income yeah
I'll people making levels and also
playing levels but it was good uh you
know I was because of so much had
already come out between that and the
smash brothers direct beforehand which I
I fell out that wasn't really excited
about that so um I guess there was i was
14 that that one big like wow moment and
it is not like a hey this is all good
like it wasn't like a WoW but it's like
this is good stuff mmm good stuff yeah
i'm really excited starfox it's one of
my favorite franchise Domino to see you
come back like we knew it was gonna come
but I actually see it I was like yes I
played it yeah so I was watching the
direct I was a little worried about a
couple things I look of it and just the
way we're controlling all that and then
I got my hands on em I alright it looks
great yeah 60 frames per sec it looks
really nice and the motion controls are
very different but not bad yeah that's
my thing is it's like when you first
play it it feels wrong because starfox
you're used to moving
ship and the radical goals with you but
with this it's a little bit more like a
duel stick shooter but instead of a
second stick it's moving the interesting
the gamepad and it kind of starts to
feel intuitive after a while I didn't
have enough time with it for it's a
click and for me to be like I love this
yeah but I'm very excited it's
definitely the game that I am looking
forward to playing the most this year oh
yeah absolutely no it's a lot of fun
like that was the thing I anytime I hear
about the motion controls I get a little
nervous but I did get to play in and the
way it works is that you're seeing the
what's going on on the screen on TV but
your gamepad is the cockpit view yeah so
you can actually move it around and yeah
i was able to pick it up and get right
into it and it was it was actually a lot
of fun i felt like i was i was flying
right there with fox in the game and it
is we go and then of course here they've
got of course the giant seats that you
can sit in a bowl and everything else no
i haven't had replica or wings yeah and
you go with them if you play it be like
you play Star Fox zero and then give you
a little badge and you get that badge
you can wait in line so like actually
get in the cockpit and play the game
yeah that's fine it's really cool so I'm
curious you know what your expectations
were for for the direct before it
happened because to me it was exactly
what i figured it was going to be to me
that knows in a very weird place right
now they're in between place wii u is
dying on the vine they can't really say
anything about NX yet so it seems to me
that you know the Mario we all wanted is
clearly not going to happen on with you
right all these kinds of things so it's
very 3ds kind of centric yeah a buttress
by Mario maker and starfox oh did you
have expectations that were greater than
that because it really meant my
expectations where which were not very
high yeah then Tyndall's always that
weird one where I feel like they get a
lot of criticism but it's because
everyone does have an expectation so
high I mean this is the console that
many people grew up with and so you you
expect so much from them so even when
they give you an okay thing people like
that it I know but I know it was really
it was really some good stuff but yeah I
think that is the same thing we see
happening this happened with Xbox when
they were transition 360 to Xbox one
sent them a ps3 ps4 you kind of get that
low period of there's still games coming
out but obviously some things are being
saved for whatever the next big thing is
and yeah that sort of thing antennas
going through there they've got some
good stuff you know you got star fox we
got yoshi
I mean I think that's the biggest yeah
issue with the direct is that we didn't
have that one big reveal surprise but
obito but we got it two days ago with
Ryu being in Smash Brothers which then
people got three days ago when he leaked
it people call it the weekend oh my god
bourbon but it's surprising to me that
we just saw three games that we'd
already known about well I guess starfox
was the first time we've really seen it
but we know was needed but they did
mention it like at the very end last
year yeah exactly and so we have starfox
we had Yoshi we have Mario maker and
it's like we're kind of underwhelmed by
that just because it's I all we know
we've seen these before but it's like no
man those games are all awesome yeah
they're really good but I think when
people think III presentation they
expect to see something that they just
never heard of before and I feel like
Xbox and Playstation did that in some
respect and nintendo was more like all
these other things seem before you know
except for Mario and Luigi paper jam
yeah which has made a lot of space jam
paper jam memes which I'm very excited
about but yeah I think that that was
probably if there was anything I was it
was missing that would be the thing is
like what game that we never had heard
of before her nintendo popping up or
even I know that Zelda Wii U which is it
gonna still be home with you was it
still and it works but being able to
maybe even just see a little bit more of
that yeah would have been nice you know
yeah definitely I mean they said it
wasn't gonna be there but hasn't you
know people lie all the time some little
tease would have been nice but it also
isn't necessary really you know like no
one predicted that they were gonna close
the show with a gameplay reveal or done
gameplay reveal of Metroid Prime that
and then just not say which system it's
on yeah you know the watchdog situation
where watch dogs were shown and you knew
was next-gen but they just couldn't say
it yeah you know I mean um but I'm we
got Metroid Prime in there yeah Oh
universe oh yeah I was like it was a
matter without yo is such a like a like
a nephew like a metroid prime one out of
the title yeah what do you think of the
Nintendo Direct format because Tim and I
were debating you know the districts and
weaknesses of the live performance like
the Microsoft the Sony kind of
I performance the vamping and all and
the reactionary kind of thing as opposed
to like the more polished this is what
we're doing we put it together weeks ago
it's perfect but there's not a lot of
room for there's not a lot of room to
maneuver that's out a lot of room to
react like kind of like Aisha at Ubisoft
where she was clearly not scripted half
the time right do you think that that
benefits then send oh that kind of
format or do you want to see them kind
of come back in a big way with a great
stage show you know I think when they do
have something really big whether it is
the next console or whatever it is I
think it would be cool for them to do
either a a presentation like like the
others do or even just something live
online because yeah there is some
advantage to that I think there is some
advantage to them being able to have
these directs I love watching them
throughout the year like it's really
cool that they do directs about specific
games you get all the details like the
smash brothers directs in the mario kart
8 dear ex that came out we're really
good but um but yeah but I think about
when uh when was the last year when the
place they should just drop the bomb on
like you can play your games on here
there's no dear I'm laughter what xbox
put out like that was a moment that
couldn't happen if they had you know
filmed the presentation a couple weeks
ago so so but then they do have the
treehouse live and they do have live
presentations going out so it's it's
definite thing like if you kind of have
to keep in mind when into no this is not
just that III presentation they have
directs before and after they have the
treehouse live throughout the week of e3
they have different ways because I think
they feel that with their fan base yeah
they're always clamoring for new
Nintendo information so they feel like
they can probably put it out a different
way than just having it right here
actually I love that I love that
throughout the year we get these like
mini directs the jazz or half hour of
just focus on games the smash bros
direct that came out like a month before
smash bros was released yeah when there
was like 30 minutes of just 50 billion
50 plus snacks it was like oh my god
that was like one of my favorite
presentations ever because it's my
favorite game yeah it's just here let's
focus on it and just announced announced
announced announced announced yeah and
they would never do that out of a press
conference or anything you know so I I
really appreciate that format I just
think it's weird that when you compare
it to the press conferences of Sony or
Microsoft because there is the audience
and there is that engagement but I I
don't think that it's that big of a deal
at the end of the day like when you're
looking at it it's like it's the same
thing there's they're announcing games
they're talking about it they have you
know Miyamoto and red
she and all that the same figureheads to
that we have over at Microsoft or Sony
like we have these characters and stuff
yeah but it is weird to not have them
you know make their weird jokes and have
it feel like oh well they're nervous and
live or it's kind of weird when they
just like make the jokes that ball flat
and that was the scripted planned right
right yeah you can kind of take you
gotta give a little leeway ways live
versus you know some people actually sat
down and planets out and it's still a
long yeah exactly that's kinda weird you
can't go wrong with Reggie fils-aime a
Miyamoto and a lot of puppets I mean
it's I heard they're called nothing my
lord intercourse what up mine up its III
you know but yeah I can understand that
like I wished if you could maybe get a
little blend of it maybe like one of the
presentations whether it's the e3 or
something is live and then some of the
other stuff is all set up I can I could
get behind that well so here's my thing
I haven't I was busy when this was
happening so I didn't really get to
watch too much of it but what I think
Nintendo did that was really cool this
year is they had the direct which was
what everyone thought it was going to be
just the you know the package that is
just on the internet and you can watch
and chat live but no audience but then
they did a Nintendo World Championships
and that was a little mean it wasn't a
press conference but there was
announcements made there was reveals
made and that was when the audience was
involved and that was our thing and they
had the people come out there was the
surprise moment said like things
happening and I think that's a really
cool format that's different oh yeah I
remember one of my friends actually
tweeted that they probably sold more
copies in Super Mario maker from the
Nintendo World Championships and they
anything they want to donate III because
you got to see it live you got to see
people playing these insane levels at
the treehouse themselves put together
yeah and it just really showcase how
that game is going to be and then once
you start figure like oh people can be
able to make these levels they're gonna
be online do you be able to share them
like that kind of experience is really
good at showing of the game and that's
something I hope that all of the
company's eventually start figuring out
what are different ways because you know
let's go sometimes those presentations
they can have their good moments again
have a la moments but sometimes are just
very cookie cutter you're gonna get the
same beach every single year so I like
it when they figure out different ways
to showcase the game that makes me go oh
I actually want to experience that I
want to play that you know a cutscene is
pretty but if I can see someone playing
the game and it's and it's live and I
could see the
I mean of those people yeah that makes
me want to play same well that's how
lets players are rocky that's all right
and when you the mario maker showing it
at the the World Championship yeah it's
like all of us like we were busy doing
so I was screaming backstage but I was
like awesome this looks awfully Twitter
was just like blowing up ya know
everyone's like oh my god like cheering
for them to try to get through the
stages and it's like that's something
special you know like I really created
this thing and like if they did that for
games like Halo or whatever it is like
creating those moments that's just more
important than it just watching a demo
be played you know yeah yeah it's just
like Jurassic world we're kind of
getting tired of the same old same old
we need indominus rex we need some more
tea well you you were part of the world
trip i was i was one of the commentators
i was part of the what they called the
underground which is if you lost the
main levels you would go down he had to
play the retro games we had Legend of
Zelda speedrun in the first dungeon we
had super metroid having to defeat
mother brain and then getting out of the
planet and then we had balloon fight
whoever could get the most and the
balloon trip balloon fight so that was a
lot of fun doing the commentary for that
very much do you think the world
championships are something that are
gonna keep bringing back I hope they do
I think it was a like i said i think was
a lot of fun and I think it was a great
way to showcase go streetball even
though they didn't call it Metroid
streetball I was just streetball there
or are our blast ball but uh I thought
it was a cool way for them to showcase
his game it also just showcase their
their top tier games right now splatoon
smash brothers mario kart so i hope they
do it again i think that could be a very
cool tradition that happens what do you
think about it call it was cool i mean i
like the idea i like you know as an
old-school nes is still my favorite
console of all time so it's like a
throwback to that golden era of nintendo
when they weren't doing that the World
Championship it's a nice throwback what
Nintendo has that no one else really has
well show me i guess is getting it
slowly because they're becoming older is
a real history yeah you know and to be
able to celebrate that history in ways
that no one else can because it's just
not chronologically possible yeah is
their advantage it's always going to be
their advantage because even the intendo
is always going to be older than sony
and xbox and and they're going to have a
history that they can celebrate so i
think doing things like that is smart
for marketing but i also think smart to
tap into the nostalgia that a lot of
people feel for nintendo including me
yes someone who feels deeply nostalgic
about nintendo and always will be but
I'm
since we have you here what do you think
about the future of Nintendo what is it
intended seems to me personally I don't
know if you agree is a company that the
last six months or a year it's finally
starting to figure things out in terms
of maybe we can't be so insular anymore
with a deal with DNA for instance to
make mobile games which i think is very
smart and an honest thing do you think
that do you think that NX is going to be
something that helps them redeem
themselves at least in the console space
we really don't know what the nature of
this thing is yeah would you see
themselves them in 35 years saying like
maybe we can put Mario on a Playstation
you know I eh possible I i think that
there's always going to be some internal
rumbling so Oh what can be allowed but I
think we are going to start seeing
Nintendo more and other things not only
does mean gaming I mean we had the big
announcement that they're going to be a
universal oh yeah and I think that
that's something in to know is realizing
is that they have a brand you know like
Disney like like anything else out there
people know these characters people grow
up with these characters they cross
generations because a kid today can play
you know mario game on new super mario
brothers when we played the regular
Super Mario Brothers back in a day so
those characters iconic so you can start
putting them into other forms and so you
know mobile I think was a great idea you
know what we see on Sony what we see it
on xbox I don't know but I mean
anything's possible but I think that
it's just nice for them to figure out
that people do like these brands and
yeah we make it our blast ball every day
on them but then again we might get
something really cool these original
cares or even if something something
doing like with the amoeba we're like yo
she can now dress up like Samus or that
you know in Mario maker you can actually
play mario levels as link or his wii fit
trainer or or stuff like that or like
how they did with the monster hunter
where you can have all the pair just
like I think Nintendo is going to start
seeing that they can do more that and
what it could help with is with some of
the third-party titles if more
third-party titles can start
incorporating into no characters in
their games it gives you exclusive like
with the Skylanders recently having
Donkey Kong and bowser in there that
makes those titles now exclusive yeah we
you existed in Nintendo and gives a
bigger reason why if you like those
characters and you like those franchises
that you will want to get the game on a
Nintendo system versus the other exactly
like NBA Street vol 3 yes yeah are you
ducking on NBA players it's always gonna
be a plus what
or this nebulous NX whatever it's going
to be what is your vision of it what
what is it that you want a next to
ultimately be when they were I don't
know I and they're very secretive and I
don't know what it's gonna be um aren't
I said it is still it's not gonna
replace Wii U or three day like that 3d
eyes like it still those it's something
that it sounds like the old like what
was a gba game cube d s kind of like
they're all go together kind of hand
really quite with three pillars whatever
yeah really quite work out that way but
yeah I mean like yeah I have a vision
for what I think this thing is that i'm
curious yeah i just i just think that it
would be interesting if we are going to
keep we are going to keep 3ds i just
feel like if there's some way that we
can make this all one coherent system I
mean that's the advantage that even over
a sony with vita the nintendo has is
they have these great games on wii u
these great games on 3ds but it's very
obvious that 3ds has a lot more and it
just seems kind of weird that you have
this game pad and it's a great game pad
it works really well but then walk so
many feet away and it's done you know so
if there's some way that they can
incorporate the wii u and 3ds together
you can play your 3ds games on wii u you
can take wii u games on the go in some
kind of form that somehow they can just
go to connect that would be the ideal
that be the ultimate because it would
get people wanting to have both consoles
so they can they be able to take all
their games everywhere and that's again
an advantage of nintendo can do being
very you know in one syncing with that
so i don't know but i don't know that's
what neck's gonna be but I just that's
what I would like to have like that is
the collective vision for a lot of
people because I was always saying it
would be cool for me personally for NX
to be something I just like the Wii U
gamepad something that's sturdier and
maybe better high fidelity and for
powerful but then you just take it yeah
then you could just beam it to your
television or just take it and yeah yeah
yeah sorry to interrupt these people she
just like a picture with them and she
doesn't know that's ratchet and that's
from galaxy okay thanks thanks so much
hahaha Joe this is kind of funny
anything can happen anytime she's nice
what you know is a crazy person that's
right [ __ ] its ratchet yeah ratchet
ratchet clank and the guy from galaxy
yeah no it'sit's okay yeah she's
somewhat obscure so I
yeah that was real good oh you I'm good
I'm good we were gonna take a break
right now don't break yet no break the
break is coming up but so what do you
also think that the next is gonna be
this kind of portable console hybrid
thing I think so but I think they're
being so you know because because you're
right on and to say that like well we
use not going anywhere in 3 s's it going
on where and I'm like is it some sort of
unifying structure some sort of like you
were like you're suggesting is it's
something Nintendo's so out of the box
and so clever in a lot of ways that it
might be something that that we can't
even really put into words or explain
because our minds aren't where they are
right now in terms of having things
together in other words I don't know
necessarily that it's a it's a piece of
hardware that is standing alone it might
be some sort of infrastructure or system
that that might fuse what already exists
maintain add on a super super Wii U
games where is my hope and my prayer
with all that said is that it's a new
piece of hardware they they can't
abandon the way you right now but they
need to ultimately abandon the wii u and
move on to something else and I guess
that's kind of it to the next question
is is Nintendo in trouble or are they
gonna be just fine do you think I think
Nintendo has got enough behind them
they're gonna be just fine but I do feel
like it did notice needs to it's a
difficult thing because I think that
they are trying to march to be their own
drummer in a way big the different type
of system but you do have people who are
in the gaming that want all the systems
to just sort of hit the same there's
always that console war when I which I
don't understand now it's not like the
days of Sega Genesis a super nintendo
it's like all the games are out there
there's so many different aims on there
including mobile you know so you can
pick and choose but I think there's
still this want from some people that
Nintendo needs to do something that
makes them right at the top again and I
think that is freaking out to do their
things a little bit differently that you
know works with their brand work system
system and if they can figure out a way
to do that plus you know something that
is successful it'll be it will be good
but you know those weeds say what you
will about them they there were a lot
sold so I think that they're not gonna
be you know asking for any queries or
anything money the money certainly not
this yea so many times you have you can
have 15 18 20 out of dollars in or chess
that could disappear like that yeah a
product right on the market they also
have a
I do something to deal with is that you
know we're getting older you know so yes
we're nostalgic about Nintendo and
growing up the NES stuff like that but
you know the kids of today are not going
to have that same experience yeah Mario
is not gonna be the same to them as it
was for us so Nintendo does have to
figure out a way of how with the current
audience do you get those iconic
characters to had that same feel or
something even stronger yeah with a next
generation because you can't ride that
hey we were big in the 80s thing for
only for so long yeah I mean I feel like
they do a pretty good job specifically
with Mario of keeping him out and having
the different types of games that he's
in and also including him in kart racers
and party games yeah all these things
and it that keeps Mario as a brand
relevant and it does reach to the point
where even if these young kids that I've
never played Mario one or god forbid
Mario 3 yeah they can go back and
experience these things that are
required gaming you know and I feel like
Nintendo does a good job of it at least
in some ways of constantly re-releasing
the old games that they had electric on
Tabo wired stuff you know Zelda's and
the Mario's and stuff and when when it's
time Metroid's and all that stuff they
do a good job of making sure that people
are educated on what they should know
you know what I mean yeah so it's I I
would love a world where NX is more of
an ecosystem maybe not so much like a
cloud based thing but something like
that where it's it's virtual console but
finally how we all want it yeah you buy
a game pot you buy super metroid and you
can play it on your 3ds your wii u me
whatever it is it's just you all necking
you can play that game I want that so
back sigh I you know as much as I love a
lot of the old Nintendo games it is
frustrating at times to see a game on
Virtual Console go do i buy this one
with you or do i buy this on 3d yes you
know it'd be nice to have a very
seamless yeah well the first one with
specifically with the wii u and trying
to get a game and then it's like oh it's
available on the eshop hey yeah only on
the way on the way yeah we yeah we mo oh
like they need to figure that stuff as
you know that sure but to be honest I
think that the storefront is something
that none of the companies have truly
figured out yet I think steam is the one
that has at best yeah but even that it's
a mess like if you if you're not
familiar with pc gaming you're not
equipped to kind of go in there with the
knowledge of finding what you're looking
for yeah you get so turned off is this
too much to handle the flip side of that
is something like the the eShop and it's
just like it's too many pictures yeah
I'm just trying two of them trying to
sell you specific things trying to
actually find what you're looking for is
a little difficult then PSN has all
these issues to of just like wait to put
the options yeah it's what classics were
here they don't work here PA and the
xbox gonna have the same thing was like
well rebec we're compatible but only
what the games are on the list yeah it
gets a little confusing with that and so
and I think that's something that that
these that they need to figure out
because it's not like in the days of
like okay this is a cartridge so we
can't upgrade into the next to some of
everything else not everything's so
digital it's great I think it's a good
idea to make as many games available as
possible eat of their older games
because you know for the next
generations you want them to go back and
play some of these classics and see the
history of a game or just see how a game
from 10 15 20 years ago still holds up
to this day you can still play an 8-bit
nintendo mario game to this day and it's
still just as enjoyable as anything is
out there today and then he's happening
but and that's why i'm really excited
about super mario maker exactly cuz
that's going to introduce that yeah so
many people yeah i mean in jindo
basically said hey you know what you
make the next Mario game we're gonna sit
back because this means that will
forever have new mario games and there's
gonna be the dedicated people to get in
there and make yeah full games you know
with levels like like the full eight
worlds and all that stuff 11 day 84 yeah
yeah exactly and I love that you can
switch the Styles between the different
types of Mario's and light yeah I I'm
interested I don't know if the physics
change between them no I don't know it
seemed pretty standard to me because I
played some of the 8-bit version in the
Mario 3 version but it's really cool and
I just like the way they have this is
some setup where when you make a stage
it goes up online there's I think
there's some kind of test they make sure
that it's a legit level that you can
actually beat and the difficulty on the
level is actually determined on how many
people play it
get through it so if it's a lot of
people are able to speed through it it's
considered an easy level but if they
find a lot of people are dying in the
level it makes it more difficult and
when you die in the game it actually
puts up little x marks to show you where
other people who play this level I've
got interesting so yeah awesome well
ladies and gentlemen we're about to bump
to a quick at break 30 seconds we'll be
right back after that we're gonna
continue talking to Andre this is gonna
be awesome talking all about Nintendo
the future and stay right here it's
going to be great